i got some bad news from my family
earlier
this week having to do with the death of
my
uncle my mother's brother my uncle amay
or as we just called him uncle aim and
he was
named after my grandfather a male
marie's
so there were there were two of them and
the news got to me
through what we can call the family
grapevine i was taking a walk here
in milwaukee enjoying the the great
weather and i got a call from my
cousin christopher that's pretty unusual
so
when he calls i know something is up and
he began by saying
i've got some bad news and i was worried
at first maybe it was his
mom or his dad uh my aunt and uncle
and he said it's it's uncle aim they
found him dead
and it turns out that he died on easter
sunday
probably of a massive heart attack he
was 73 years old
and you know i'm going to tell you a
little bit about his his life and you
can see that
you know in many respects he had a very
rich and full life but also
in many respects a kind of truncated
life
as as well and it's you know we could
have expected him to live much longer
but in some respect it's uh
it's really great that he lived as long
as he did
he was uh for a good portion of my life
my absolute favorite uncle and i'm gonna
tell you some of the stories about that
and it's not that he quit being my
favorite it's
rather that you know i've got three
uncles
on my on my mom's side uh aim
john his brother and then scott my aunt
bibian's uh
husband and i you know i always clicked
with uncle aim
since i was a kid and it took a much
longer time for me to
work out a relationship in the way that
i have with with scott
and with with john who are you know kind
of different people
and so um you know i love all of them
and i i still do love my uncle aim quite
a bit
and so you know there's there's a lot
that i've been reflecting on
over the past couple days i should
mention too
some of you know that i on my my
mother's side and
that's my adoptive mother i belong to a
family that
is you know anthropologically something
almost like a clan
structure there's there's so many of us
we trace back to
um these these lamries who came out of
quebec and
during you know during the civil war
here in america
and then just kept bringing in you know
brides and husbands from quebec
uh to you know the new england when they
lived there
and then chicago where they they moved
to in the 30s
and lived until the 1970s and so family
reunions which have been going on
wow since i was a little kid they
involve you know anywhere from 70 to 200
people
and you know everybody knows like where
do you fit in
in this this family structure and i'm
from the generation that
grew up speaking english instead of
french
first i i learned some french because of
my mom and also because of uncle aim
and uncle john swearing all the time uh
and talking in
in french that generation and so
you know i wanted to to tell some
stories about this guy
and anyway the going back to like the
big family so i was
you know talking with my cousin chris
walking down the street
getting some particulars catching up
with him a bit and then i got another
call
on the phone at the same time you know
and i didn't want to click over with
call waiting
so i waited until i got off the phone
with chris and then looked to it was
it was uncle john and aunt mary and they
were calling basically with the same
news
about uncle aim and so you know we
talked about that and i did my duty of
like passing on the news to my kids
and then earlier today i talked with my
aunt bib and we actually
talked for close to an hour i'd say
she was the person who i figured would
probably be the most
you know sad and broken up about it
and and one of the things that she did
say is you know so
aim lived in the house that belonged to
my grandfather and grandmother
in indiana on what we call the compound
it's not like a walled compound or
anything but
you know grandfather uh
two of his brothers and actually
grandma's
sister who was married to one of
grandpa's brothers
they all built houses on this land in
indiana and they have a common driveway
uncle hubert and antarese never had
children and so they lived in another
house and uh then uncle ernie and aunt
betty
uh bought another house which is where
bib and scott live and so bib
you know she was telling me today that
you know she could always like look out
the window and see
that aim was in the house by like maybe
the glow of the tv or a light being on
and now it's now it's completely dark
for the very first time
since those houses were built in 1975
there's nobody actually living
in that particular house and
that's a good place to sort of jump off
so you know my
my grandpa and his whole generation they
built those houses out in indiana they
moved out of chicago where they were
that where they were living on on a
block that was almost all french
canadians and menominee indians
and had its own church son jean-baptiste
and they they got out of the city when
when they retired
and bib actually finished her high
school there
aim was older aim was my mom's brother
just a year younger than her
and so you know he had done
uh quite a few things aim was
was severely bipolar and
that went undiagnosed when he was a kid
um as
as things typically did for that
generation
even from my generation and so he
you know he was just viewed as like a
screw-up in some respects and he got
kicked out of high school
wound up joining the air force got his
ged there
and you know he was always kind of a
charismatic personality especially when
he was younger
you know you look at pictures of him he
was very very good looking
interestingly enough i'll tell you
another thing too
grandpa so aim senior
lem reese aim junior and christopher
if you look at photographs of them from
when they were like
babies to like teenagers they look like
exactly the same person
as does my my mom you know who's
deceased
and my cousin jeannette there's some
really interesting similarities of
looks in the family and anyway aim you
know kind of bounced around
and did a lot of things and he actually
got married he lived in an apartment in
madison
um in the same apartment complex as my
mom and dad when my dad
was going to to college there and
you know then things fell apart and um
there was actually a cousin named named
amy who
we know now and she was called mimi she
was born three days before
me and um aim you know that's amen and
kathy's daughter
and they call this night and day because
you know i was bald and very
pasty and she was you know she had dark
hair and it was was uh fairly tan
and and you know we'd play together and
stuff but then aim
you know essentially lost his marriage
lost his daughter because of
a breakdown and you know he ended up
living with
grandpa and grandma they had a room in
the basement that they built for him
and he you know he would have these
things and then he'd sort of cobble his
life back together
and in any case
i grew up spending a lot of time out
there in indiana you know that's where
we'd have
all the major occasions christmas easter
you know
we'd go out there if we if we weren't
going into chicago with uncle john and
aunt mary
and so i spent much of my childhood
um seeing aim all the time
and actually he would come to our place
out in you know the border of delafield
and wales too he would drive up
my mom would sometimes you know she'd
she'd actually call him
and his brother john if something was
broken down
john was a sears repairman and aim was a
you know sort of master carpenter
and they were both very handy and so
they
you know some sometimes one would come
up and the other one wouldn't or
sometimes both of them would come up and
um you know they did a lot of stuff and
so i i saw my uncle aim all the time
and and my family i'll mention again you
know it this this
clan structure and the way that
everybody grew up
and the way that we were connected with
each other cousins are about as close
as many people's brothers and sisters
and you know more extended cousins like
the people that you
really wouldn't think you know are
treated the way that other people treat
their
cousins and you know
there's also this kind of feature of
you've got kids but everybody kind of
you know watches out for the kids
and so uncles and aunts especially if
they're childless can often be
pretty similar to moms and dads and
you know aim there's a lot of things
that that we did together i remember i
would stay out there quite
often in the summer now that i think
about it my mom and dad would sometimes
send my sister to uncle john and aunt
mary's and me to indiana
basically to have some time to
themselves and have us out of their hair
for for a while when we were kids and i
i loved it i loved being out there
you know out in the sticks helping out
with the gardening and you know
just like walking for miles and miles
through
uh forest some of them pine some of them
you know pin
oak and stuff like that and through
meadows and aim would would take me on
these really long walks where we'd go
along the drainage ditches
that whole area used to be the grand
kankakee marsh and so drainage stitches
are very important and we'd you know
we'd do things like pick berries or
you know throw stones and just just kind
of you know pal around
really we'd also go on long drives he
had a
truck that he you know really that was
his truck this red truck and
he always had other trucks later on and
and you know i would
get together with him he said let's go
for a drive and we'd be like you know in
illinois
and driving around and he'd he knew he'd
always take back roads
that thing over there that's the story
of that and we'd you know stop at places
and you know when i got older have
coffee
and he'd chat with people and you know
it was
it was quite quite enjoyable i remember
riding along
in the truck back then he smoked and and
i was you know that
until my later teenage years i didn't
but i remembered the smell of the
tobacco as we'd be driving along and
he'd be
ashing out the window and we'd just talk
sometimes or drive along
and he was also
you know an incredible wood carver he
had some
some real talent unfortunately
after he started you know going on on
the medication that he really needed
some of that got got tamped down but i
remember
every christmas in the 1970s and early
80s there would be these
amazing wood carvings that he would do
sometimes from patterns sometimes just
from what he would
visualize in his own mind
and you know he could he could take a
block of wood and
whittle a chain of links that were
interconnected he could
he he actually carved a mobius strip one
time just to do it
so pretty impressive stuff and he got my
sister and i
into wood carving as well he would buy
us knives at christmas
and you know basswood to work on and i i
actually
did quite if i was into fish at the time
and so i carved quite a few
fish as best as i could and you you
would you know he'd be you'd be carving
and he'd be like oh
that's that's pretty good you know he
showed you how to use not just knives
but also
the chisels and the
the gouges and you know he's also very
careful don't cut yourself on these
and we did a lot of other things
together when it came to wood i'll just
tell you
a few stories i'm probably going to do
more than one of these videos because
there's so many
stories to tell about the guy
i remember being in a school play that
i had i had written and it was not a i
don't think it's a very good play at all
it's long lost but my dad caught me
working on it and it was kind of a
fantasy thing not particularly well put
together
i was drawing on lloyd alexander's
pridian chronicles you know
and in any case there was a time machine
and that's how he explained how the
characters got there
so the lots of sword play lots of you
know fighting and stuff like that
and i made myself you know a replica
sword
that was kind of straight i basically
took some wood that i'd found at a
construction site and worked on it
and aim you know found out about this
play and we were there
at thanksgiving and he was like well
you know what kind of sword would you
like to have and i was like a scimitar
and he was like okay let's uh let's
think about how that would work
and you know he had this all this
woodworking stuff in the basement and
he's like
all right let's uh start cutting the
sword and figure out how we're going to
make this you're going to help me with
it
but of course he was really doing the
whole show and he made me this amazing
wooden replica scimitar
which then of course i ended up breaking
when we were screwing around at the play
and i had
to screw back together um but he would
he would just do stuff like that he was
very generous with his
time another thing that was kind of cool
in terms of
of woodworking that happened later on
actually i've got two really cool
stories about woodworking later on
so when i was
i want to say 15
or so maybe yeah i think i was 15
so it was the summer in between
sophomore and junior year
i was i was in indiana and my mom was
there and my sister was there
and aim was was there as well and by
then he had moved out he was living in
in tonica
at this he was boarding with a lady we
called aunt rose now she wasn't actually
an aunt she wasn't actually related to
us but she was from the block in chicago
she was an old italian lady
and she'd moved out to that area and a
lot of the cousins had moved out to
prue lasalle area and so they everyone
knew her and and so aim was was boarding
with her
and he was doing work on one of their
neighbors places you know kind of
at first it was odd jobs then it was
like you know um it was supposed to be
painting but there are the houses that
they wanted painted
they bought this big farm there was a
lot of rot and stuff and so he was like
well i'm gonna have to like replace
these boards here and
fix this and so he was like hey do you
want to come out and like
stay with me for like you know two weeks
and we'll we'll knock this job out it'd
be really handy to have an apprentice to
to help me out and you can learn some
stuff on the way and so i was like can i
do that mom and she was like
yeah go ahead and so you know we drove
down
and i stayed there with him at ant roses
and every day we went out there in the
blazing heat and we worked on their
the corcoran's house and you know we we
ended up
he showed me how to like you know how to
tell when the board needed to be
replaced and
how to do that and then he showed me how
to glaze windows
and you know we did a lot of painting
which i already knew how to do anyway
but you know
that was that was the fun stuff and then
you know we we
he drove me back to my mom's uh place
by then my dad had died so it was just
you know my mom's place
and that was a that was a cool summer
you know i stayed at his
eventually had a house in tonic and i
stayed at his place
shortly before i went in the army in the
middle of a really
cold winter i stayed there when i was in
grad school
a couple times you know i stopped there
with with a girlfriend when i was in uh
college and we we stayed at his place
for for a few nights and
there's a lot of stories i'll tell about
him and tonica later on i think but the
other the other woodworking story i'll
tell is
um when i was you know i bought one of
those houses with my inheritance from
when my mom died
the one that uncle hubert and aunt honey
had and
i wanted to frame out walls and stuff in
the basement
and i'd never actually done that
so i you know i knew he could do a lot
of carpentry and i was like is this hard
to do and he's like
[ __ ] easy come on let's go to the
lumber yard
first i'll show you how to pick out some
lumber that isn't all screwed up
you know we're gonna look down the
boards and and all that okay you got
your lumber
now let's go and um start figuring out
where you want your walls to go
and we'll start framing him out and so
he he walked me through doing one he's
like all right i think you're good
i'll come back tonight and see how the
other how the other walls are and he
came in and some of them were
were pretty decent and then he was like
that one i think we're gonna have to
take down and redo from from the ground
up
um and it was you know it was it was
cool he was showing me like which nails
to use to get it into the concrete or
into the um cinder block you know which
to use just
uh for for putting the studs in
and and all that and so you know he he
was a very
uh handy guy that way
and i learned i learned quite a bit from
him
in various um situations
he also i'll tell you this story and
then i'll bring it to a close because
this is already getting a little bit
long and i can tell more stories about
aim down the line
but i think those those of you who are
my viewers in a philosophy focused
channel will be interested in this
he was the guy who gave me my first book
of philosophy
you know he was at that time he was
again living with grandpa and grandma in
the basement
and spending a lot of time like
listening to the radio and reading books
and
you know i'd wander in and and you know
we'd chat about stuff
and he had this book you know albert
camus the myth of
sisyphus and and other essays too and i
was like oh i like greek mythology and
he's like well
it's not exactly greek mythology and i
was like can i
can i check it out he says you can have
it you know
i've read it through you go ahead and
take it
and i thought it was gonna be about
greek mythology and it does talk about
greek mythology at the very end right
where we must imagine sisyphus happy but
the rest of it i mean it begins with you
know the only philosophical question is
that of suicide and
you know there's all this other stuff
going on and you know i think i
you know i didn't actually know most of
the names he's referring to and i i
doubt i followed even one-tenth of what
was being said in the book
i did read the other essays in there um
about like you know shoe shoes and
getting them polished in iran and things
like that i don't remember them too well
but
it was always cool he you know my uncle
hubert who had a
a big library he was always cool with
lending out books
but so was aim and so in some respects
he's maybe played a little role in me
getting on the road to
philosophy and i'd say he did in other
ways too because we'd have you know
cool deep conversations especially as
we're taking these
drives or walks and so
you know he he was somebody who played a
really big role
in my life in my childhood in my
20s actually i'm going to close on a
different
topic you know his generosity
when i was in my 20s when i was in
college
you know i i'd work i i didn't have an
awful lot of money
to to spend on on much of anything
and you know i was working minimum wage
jobs and at that time he was working
in a machine shop so it was not a great
job but you know not
not a terrible job either and he was
living out in his little house and
tonica
and all of that and we'd be there at
christmas time
and it was kind of a big deal that i was
going to college because
you know not that many people in my
family the large
extended family went to college in
in my generation until later on and
the ones that did were kind of you know
the hoity-toity branches right
and so everyone was very proud of me
going to college especially since my dad
had gone to college
and all of that um and so he would take
me aside at christmas time
and he'd just you know peel off a couple
hundreds
in his wallet um one time it was
actually 500
and he'd he'd you know say here you go
and i was like what's that what's this
for he said merry christmas man
uh i know you can use it you know you
got books to buy you got you know
things to do and that
generosity came in so
handy at times when i quite often was
you know pretty broke
and you know it wasn't it wasn't just
like he was just you know demonstrating
his large ass that was a good bit of
money for him
too um he wasn't making a ton of money
at the machine shop but
he uh he wanted to help me out and he'd
always say don't tell anyone about this
but i'm telling people about it now
he was a cool guy uncle aim and i'm
going to miss him a lot
even though you know i haven't seen him
for over a year because
kovid and he you know he he changed
as he got older um we we didn't spend
that much time
together over the last i would say 10
years
um but he's he's somebody
who really was an important part of my
life
so i thought i would share some of that
with you
you know some sadness comes and goes for
all of us
but he had a a pretty decent life
overall
and um you know despite some serious
challenges he
he was a pretty good guy so i'll tell
you more about him some other time
you